I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the ushi ushinomi which
turns its user into a bison it was eaten
by Dalton the new king of Chopper's
Island and just like any other animal
type devil fruit the Bison fruit gives
you a strong boost in terms of power and
a variety of Transformations between
human and animal and even among animals
a bison is a truly giant and Powerful
one 16 out of 25 points and similarly
animal fruits also significantly beef up
both defense and Recovery another
utterly impressive 16 points here
however since a bison is just a regular
animal and not a mythical creature it
doesn't give you any special abilities
yet it still wouldn't be a bad fruit to
have in real life at all you can run
quite fast eat grass have horns and stay
warm in winter this deserves a
magnificent 12 points there are no real
downsides or weaknesses to this fruit
either earning it a legendary 44 points
putting it on the podium at number 3 of
our list for now